Charlie Sykes how are you good are you
it's it's it's a pleasure
this is especially with our the last
year it's this kind of an opportunity
that perhaps you and I would never have
and I'm looking forward to it in well
this is the book I'm sure you everyone
watching has already seen this what was
interesting for me and being asked to do
this is I'm not on the opposite side of
you when it comes to President Trump but
the first sentence in your book is this
is not a book about Donald Trump right
how the right lost its mind is the title
immediately you you're taking a stand
with the title but what I'd like to do
is to make sure everybody knows who's
watching what your background is what
you've done you've written a number of
other books the conservatives who have
supported Trump and do support Trump
will find probably a great deal in
common
that they have with you on the issue of
the Academy freedom of expression etc
and and yet they see you I'm I tweeted
we were doing this and some tweets came
back why are you doing that he's a never
Trump er what I'd like to do first since
everyone watching no doubt would have a
different idea of what conservatism is
before we get into the meat of this and
I'll also be talking to you about your
own background explain to everyone fruit
for who's listening politically and
otherwise what conservatism means to you
well that's interesting question because
of course that's up in the air it seems
to be being redefined on a regular basis
but for me conservatism was all about
limited government fiscal responsibility
individual freedom respect for the
Constitution those sorts of things kind
of an inclusive aspirational vision that
I think was really very very well
captured by by Ronald Reagan we talked
about America being a shining city on a
hill I think I come from a brand of
conservatism that is reform oriented
that wants to actually deal with
problems that they exist in the real
world but very much the kind of
conservatism that I think was defeated
in in the Republican primaries in 2016
and that is a clear part of your book
obviously but with a title like this how
the right lost its mind not how I think
conservatism is a longer word maybe
that's the difference and as it fits on
on the read Trump cap is it really a
decision kind of point that's happened a
transitionary point that's been achieved
of people abandoning something or is it
possible there's just simply we're in
the midst of a transition if you will
when it comes to what people want what
they've seen whether they think it's
failed they don't like what's happened
up to this point or they feel the GOP
hasn't delivered is it possible that in
fact people haven't lost their mind but
were in a position of transition at this
stage politically we are in a position
of transition but there was also a clear
break I mean what happened in 2015 and
2016 was a dramatic moment for the
conservative movement that I think was a
rejection of much of the conservative
tradition I think it was a rejection of
much of the Reagan legacy I think that
many of the things that happen during
this campaign when the title of the book
you know has two meanings which is the
you know how the right lost its mind
which was the rejection of a lot of the
intellectual tradition of mainstream
conservatism by Donald Trump and and by
the his supporters in the Republican
Party but it was also just the quite
frankly the the kind of the crazy that
that that invaded the party they the the
explosion of hoaxes of extreme positions
the willingness to tolerate bizarre
behavior a lot of that a lot of that
happens so there's kind of a double
meaning now in terms of is is it done is
it over no this is an ongoing debate I
think we're going to have this debate
for a generation a lot of people
watching myself and myself being here
also supporting the president there it
was a a relationship that developed my I
first supported Scott Walker was not
supportive of the president first grew
into the nature of supporting him I have
not been disappointed however I've
warned my listeners is a radio talk-show
host as well that we will be
disappointed at some points like we are
with all politicians
is it a lot of people I think would
argue that this really is about the
establishment leadership not delivering
that we do love Reagan we are children
of Reagan if you will that that all of
what you stated in the beginning we also
believe in and yet we've watched
government get bigger 20 trillion dollar
debt Obama care and that current
betrayal that we've experienced spending
in general the the largesse a government
being made bigger deliberately literally
by george w bush that perhaps it's
because we're children of reagan and
that we haven't seen that continue some
would argue that what happened last year
is in fact a reassertion of an
insistence that we go back to the
conservative ideal yeah well hey there
may be people who want to go back to the
conservative eddy who felt betrayed by
the republican establishment the donald
trump was not the guy i mean five
minutes ago he was a democrat he was
contributing money to Hillary Clinton
and to Chuck Schumer when he was first
running there was a question did he
support single-payer health care he's
even a supporter of abortion right look
Donald Trump is not it never has been an
actual conservative in part because he
is a man
utterly lacking in principle who has
spent less than five minutes thinking
about issues and even many of the
supporters I think understand that with
with Donald Trump maybe he's the vehicle
to break the status quo but he doesn't
represent an idea he doesn't represent a
well-thought-out philosophy of
government and again we have to play
this out we don't know what is his
relationship with Nancy and Chuck going
to be a month from now two months from
now a year from now after the midterm
elections so you know for people who
were saying we're we're upset with the
establishment because they have not
given us conservative values there were
I think 1716 candidates they were on
that stage and almost every one of them
had stronger conservative credentials
actually understood issues actually
understood policy and had principles and
yet the Republican
rejected all of those other
conservatives for Donald Trump that
wasn't about conservatism well it it
could be about and this is where perhaps
the GOP but part of your book is also
about
giving advice to conservatives and we
can get to that but as we establish kind
of our positions here and where people
like us go as we move forward that the
rejection of individuals who were seen
as with the establishment same as when
Eric Cantor was effectively fired that
we saw that the trend to this of a
wholesale rejection of and the other men
who were running and the woman Carly
Fiorina who at one point also supported
really did represent the standard that
this was a wholesale rejection of what
was seen as a failure of the standard
and as a message to be sent that it's it
and I think this is where the divide is
that it's less a rejection of
conservatism and more a rejection of
those who haven't moved it properly or
who say they're conservatives but where
we've seen well the next in line john
mccain mitt romney and then we see the
world yeah we see the world unfold and
the ability also to deal with the world
in its new face with electronics social
media the internet is that part of the
issue not just media but how you
interact on all of these formats which
Trump did very well at and in talking to
people directly and being able to
communicate with them which I don't
think any of the other people stand
standing on those on that debate stage
were able to do with the exception
perhaps of Carly Fiorina
but even she wasn't able to translate it
to the ground is it about being
communicators in a new age where as
President Reagan didn't even have to
deal with talk radio or anything on
social media so and and by the way that
this is an interesting point that during
the Reagan era you didn't have the kind
of
of conservative media echo chamber that
you and I are both both part of and I
wonder whether his success might have
had something to do with always that yes
and I think it's kind of it's one of
those interesting puzzles what what role
they played there but look um you know
not Donald Trump represented something
he certainly represented a you know what
the big middle finger from from voters
to the establishment but if you really
really wanted to to deal with some of
these issues you would have gone you
being the Republican electorate would
have gone with a Marco Rubio or a Scott
Walker or a Ted Cruz or a Carly Fiorina
and and they didn't and in terms of
communication yes he's a master of
Twitter but he was crude he was rude he
was a serial liar he is thin-skinned
he's erratic he's a fraud and this was
that well this was but this was
relatively well known and conservatives
who you know not that long ago used to
argue that character matters that the
president was a role model have somehow
found a way to rationalize the behavior
of somebody who insults women mocks the
disabled mocks POWs he's paid a
multi-million dollar fine for defrauding
students who just wanted to get an
education
who who even now is sitting in the Oval
Office uses his power to insult and to
call for people to be fired for engaging
in free speech and yet we are supposed
to think somehow this is a return to
conservative values I I don't know if
anybody's that's interesting though
because I don't know if that election
was that argument no I was making it
wasn't but no one's saying that this is
a return to conservative values in a
sense that it was in fact an effort to
put out the dumpster fire that was
happening economically and wasn't still
is happening around the world and as
I've mentioned in CBS had had a panel
three women two African American women
and a white woman about our age asking
them about his comments after after
Charleston yeah if it bothered them
all of them said no you know that that
they they weren't voting for a husband
or a boyfriend that it was about getting
things in order and that's the thing
that's resonated about you know with the
role of the president the nature of this
person as an individual and what was
required at the moment and if and
clearly people determined that it wasn't
going to be Chris Christie or Marco
Rubio or Jeb Bush that it is a statement
at least worthy of taking seriously and
in your book the the implication is is
that the voters or at least the trend in
the Republican Party which I'm not a
Republican is of xenophobia and racism
and misogyny and for the average voter
who wants their wants a their jobs back
who wants health care dealt with who
wants money back in their pocket and
wants to see the future is that fair to
all of those individuals who you know
acknowledge that on occasion we're going
to be offended but that there's
something larger at stake is it fair in
in that kind of a view point to the
voters themselves Tuesday what - well as
in your book to say that this was a
movement or what he represents was was
xenophobia and misogyny and racism that
that by implication is well that's what
well I mean he obviously trafficked in
it there's no question about it his
attitude towards women we don't need to
rehash it I mean we we had in one camera
there was once a time when if somebody
bragged on camera about sexually
assaulting women that would be
disqualifying and certainly
conservatives would have thought so the
the blaming the his his attitudes on
other things that well now does that
mean that the voters are racist or
sexist no it's not and then and and and
I think that's where a lot of people on
the Left have have made a terrible
mistake you know they played the race
card so often that it's lot lost
meanings I think they spend 30 years
crying
they said that john mccain was a racist
they said that Mitt Romney's a racist
George Bush's erases Ronald Reagan's a
racist every conservative was a racist
so when the real thing came along in the
form of the alt-right which was clearly
empowered and encouraged by the Trump
campaign in which he continues to give
winks and nods to when the real thing
came along the left was out of
ammunition and I think folks on the
right had become numb to it but here's
the moral to test you know are they part
of our tent is the alt-right part of the
conservative movement William F Buckley
Jr back in the 1960s drew a line and
said the John Birch Society needed to be
excommunicated from the conservative
movement because they were too extreme
they were crackpots and he successfully
did it not because he was a RINO not
because he was not any communist but
because you know if you made place for
these conspiracy theories back jobs who
said the Dwight Eisenhower was a
communist agent you were gonna discredit
your movement well we don't have
gatekeepers like that anymore we don't
have anyone who has the ability to say
okay listen we have to draw the line so
what happened was we had a conservative
movement that turned a blind eye and
again I'm not saying that all
conservatives of this that's not true
but we turned a blind eye let's be
honest about this
we turned a blind eye to the conspiracy
theorists the paranoid to people who
traffic in in racist false stories we
being that concern well pretty much all
of us I mean I tried to push back on
some of the stuff but the in media or in
median end well Donald Trump began his
presidential rise by pushing the Barack
Obama birther conspiracy theory who
pushed back against him a majority of
Republican voters at one time believe
that and the reality is that we kind of
figured these were the fringes they were
the extremes we could sort of roll our
eyes and the center would hold but it
didn't and I think this was a moral
failure on the part of conservatives so
look I don't think the conservatives are
racist misogynist Senna phobic but I do
think that we if we're honest in this
moment in the wilderness that we have
now to to ask whether or not we ignored
it and we were way too
all of it because we figured they're on
our side and we're not going to call
them out on it
so after Charlottesville that was a real
signal that was one of those moments and
you know you bring it up we look to our
president to provide moral leadership to
provide moments of healing and of unity
and that was one of those moments where
Donald from I think failed signaling but
again if you'd followed what he did
during the campaign this should not have
come as a surprise well in the aftermath
of that of course we've had larger
discussion about anti Fah right the
president and we know this being in
media and we know this also in how media
can distort or mislead or even directly
lie it's certainly about Republicans and
conservatives that's generally what they
do is part of this issue perhaps that
media decides what is going to be
elevated that they're going to decide
the narrative that the the elevation or
the depiction of the reach of the
alt-right is is it a mistake perhaps to
think of the conservative movement are
all conservatives versus what CNN or
MSNBC or the New York Times or any other
element that has an agenda is deciding
to elevate and promote that the
difference between and I tell my
audience this all the time is to not let
the media determine your reality to look
to a broader base of information and for
those of us in the media that is our
bubble in a way is it possible that we
are mistaking or you're mistaking the
power and influence of that group that
we recognize has got some issues as
being some issues it's got some major
issues and ya know today I would not
describe neo-nazis and the kuku issue no
no I'm not talking I'm talking about
this is also the difference between
talking about what is a conservative and
the difference with what is the alt
right Breitbart calm some people they're
what Milo represents versus a guy in the
Klan
suit so this is where we begin to
conflate things and I don't know for a
lot of people even listening and we
would even have disagreements about do
we have a definite definition of what
the alt-right is versus white
supremacists or is this the conflation
and is that what we're going to do but
we don't even have agreements on that a
lot of people look at Breitbart for
information because they support Donald
Trump they're regular people people at
Breitbart calm are going to have a
variety of opinions we've and some are
repulsive some are not you can find that
at any network people yet but it depends
on what we're going to promote is it
Breitbart is it today all right well
Breitbart I mean Steve Bannon who went
on to become top aide to the president
knighted States bragged at one point
that he had turned Breitbart into a
platform for the all right let's be
clear the alt-right is really a
euphemism for you know white nationalism
and any anti-semites and you could be
correct but there are people that would
disagree with that and and this is where
this is where the debate is and at least
the discussion is about what it is I'm
and I think most people listening are
going to have the different opinion or
even themselves be conflicted we know
what the Nazis in the Klan are I think
most people would say that that's not
Breitbart and that's not fair but it
also means that it might not be
everything that they believe or that we
or that she's not hard this is really
not hard see this is not hard to
denounce these extremists here this is
you know and and and this is we this is
part of I think what's happened to
conservatives with Donald Trump that's
something that would have been easy and
automatic has now become difficult
people who are white nationalist white
supremacist they are not part of our
movement that's not who we already know
this seems 23 years you know I have
struggled against this stereotype of the
left you know that you people are this
and so no no no we're not we are not
like this we are do not we do not make
excuses we do not rationalize and then
along comes the all right and suddenly
it's like well maybe there were many
good people there look this is the
president I'd stayed who looks at these
guys marching with tiki torches and said
there were lots of good
people there and he looks at NFL players
and I disagreed with much of what they
didn't call them sons of [ __ ] you
know it's there there there's a point at
which you have to say the conservative
movement needs to pass some moral tests
so you were asking about the media and I
think there is no such thing as the
media anymore
it does not exist there are multiple
forms of the media and you and I are
part of the alternative media where
where we created the other side of the
story so the mainstream media could not
set the agenda I mean there's there was
a time when you know people sitting at
CBS ABC and NBC they determined what was
the news and if they ignored something
it wasn't news remember all that you
know and then suddenly came along
alternative media conservative talk
radio and this was a wonderful thing
because suddenly now we could talk about
issues that people cared about we didn't
look down on people it was the other
side of the story
but something has happened where those
competing that diversity of voices did
become for many Americans on both the
right and the left these alternative
reality silos they have their own
narratives their own facts that we don't
communicate we are in intellectual
ghettos we are in these these these echo
chambers bubbles whatever you want to
call them and as a result of that what
happens is our political debate really
has been dumbed down and you do have the
fake news the propaganda you know the
bright parts of the world that that can
you know I I think can you distort
reality in the way and of course there
does is is the mainstream media bias
absolutely there's no question about it
but also we're at a point now there's a
reason why we use terms like post truth
era post factual era where we have a
tolerance for propagate where we've lost
the ability to distinguish between
propaganda and reality and that's
dangerous and that's something that
conservatives should not be part of we
ought to be a reality based movement if
our arguments are better if our facts
are better then we don't need to stay
within our alternative reality silo well
so I identify as a conservative I'm also
a feminist and when it comes to like
with
Trump and what media can do talking
about there were good people at
Charlotte's ville we know that there
were people from the city people were
going there to be against the Nazis in
the Klan other people were there who
were not with them because they cared
about the historical relevance regarding
a statue or they didn't want that to be
torn down who also were not of course in
league with white supremacists and it
was a mix of people who were there and I
think that and this is one of the
problems when we we hear what we want to
hear or or choose to promote what we
want to be the case is that Trump and
mentioning there are lots of good people
there or good people in general at
Charlottesville would be true that
you're either not only associated with
anti-shah if you are protesting against
the statue and you didn't need to be
associated with the Klan or the Nazis if
you're protesting for the Statue to stay
and this is where I think also in our
world where at least with talk radio and
on c-span and book TV we have more time
that one statement one word then can be
expanded out based on our opinion of I
think of the person or expectations and
then that becomes the truth or the
judgment and then someone like myself in
saying well this is what I heard and I
don't believe in to be in that fashion
then then am judged as being either a
polluter or also a racist how do we
bridge that gap with two people who
generally agree on most issues who are
seeing things differently because I
think of the passion and forming the
informing the debate well again there
there are we need to have these
conversations but I spent a good deal of
time in this book talking about the all
right yes yeah the role that they play
and who they are and what they believe
and how they represent a thorough
repudiation of American conservative
values you know I'm a conservative who
believes that America should be the
shining city on the hill that we are
based on an idea they reject the idea
they reject the values of the
Declaration of Independence rather
explicitly
they don't believe that America is an
idea they believe that it is a
geographical location people by people
of certain ethnic and racial backgrounds
and there's a real dark side there and
the reality is is that throughout the
campaign Donald Trump had more than one
opportunity to repudiate them reject
them speak out against them and he
dodged and delayed and winked again and
again and again it's a pattern it's not
this is not a one-off this is a problem
this is a cancer at the heart of the
conservative movement if we are not
willing to say that the left is not
right that we tolerate these people so
there are these moral judgments these
key moments in every movement you know
liberalism had to expel the Communists
in the late 1940s conservatism had to
expelled the Birchers in the 60s we have
to deal with the alt-right and
unfortunately you know had donald trump
been defeated in this election i think
that would have been a reckoning among
conservatives about how this had
happened but now some of these folks
mean there shouldn't be any under
misunderstanding they do feel empowered
they do feel emboldened by this current
political environment and conservatives
who recognize them for what they are
really need to be outspoken about this
this is this is our test right now our
time so even with there's been many
changes the president's made and with
Steve Mann and being out of the White
House Mike Pence being his choice for
vice president do you see with this
dynamic Mike other individuals out other
people coming in as the chief of staff a
variety of different kinds of approaches
now have taken old versus his initial
choices and decisions what do you
think's happening in this process it's
been about nine months are you
heartened by some of the changes that
have been made do you think where he's
on the right path do you think that this
is finally settling down a little bit
about who's where and and what
conservatism means well those are almost
two separate issues but yes there are a
number of appointments that have to be
very very encouraging I mean clearly the
the
best thing that the president has done
so far has been the appointment of a
Supreme Court justice I think people
should have a lot of confidence in some
of the grown-ups in the administration
although by the time people watch this
some of those grown-ups may be gone from
the administration considering the
management by humiliation that Donald
Trump has presided over you know Donald
Trump presided over a shambolic
transition he was unqualified and unfit
to be President and proved that almost
from the moment he walked in the door by
peopling it with people who had no idea
what they were doing and created the
chaos around him but this presidency is
not really shaped by his staffing this
presidency is shaped by the character
and judgment of Donald Trump he's a 70
year old man he's not going to change so
we'll we'll see you know give it give it
a give it a few minutes obviously
general Kelley has not been able to
control the Twitter feed and in terms of
conservatism keep in mind again if we
acknowledge the Donald Trump is not a
conservative that he's a man of no fixed
principles whatsoever whose ignorance of
the issues you know is made manifest on
a regular basis then it's hard to see
that you're going to have a dramatic
turning point so what is the future of
conservatism is he going to be a
conservative leader or worried is he
going to start and move and begin
working with the Democrats is he going
to if he makes an alliance with with
Chuck and Nancy will you still argue
that this is a great conservative moment
that that the conservative movement is
is intact as conservatives rationalize
and defend him I don't think I think
many people have never viewed him as a
conservative in that fashion that this
was about a Reformation it was about
getting someone in who would understand
business who could be able to make
decisions who could get things done well
it's this is part of the other problem
when you look at his approval rating
today is the highest it's been since the
inauguration Congress is going between
eight to ten percent Americans still see
an obstructive dynamic and yes that part
of his job is to get things done in
Congress but Americans aren't seeing
that he's the problem that they're
seeing the same thing that we've seen
for decades about whether
get done in Congress what kinds of
things do move forward is it really
about limited government is it really
about handling the budget properly and
Americans aren't seeing that when it
comes to who's getting something done
they're not blaming him which Americans
are we talking about because I seen his
polls no American president has had
lower approval ratings in his first year
than Donald Trump these are historically
low ratings certainly that I think we'd
love to have a president we have 60% of
more of Americans who do not think that
he is level-headed or fit for office
they are embarrassed by him his approval
rating has been in the 19 so which
Americans are we talking about we're
talking about the same America though
who's giving him well you know he's
under 50% but who are giving Congress 8
and 10% right so it's it's that America
who is looking at the spectrum viewing
him more positively at least but it
could be higher but it disastrously for
for Congress and so in the political
element of this Americans are watching
and are assessing in a certain way and
it seems I guess for most people who
voted for him that we are we want him to
be successful because we want the
country to be we've seen of course the
markets go up we've gotten I think four
trillion more dollars in the marketplace
because of the stock market people are
anticipating the issue with the tax cuts
if this is another test for Congress
p.m. the president well and this is all
about governing absolutely and also
bringing on a first Reince Priebus him
and Mike Pence to get things done with
Congress finding a way to do that but
it's also about governing you're
absolutely correct and this is a test
now for both Congress and the president
but the Obamacare dynamic I think is key
as a microcosm of what people were
rejecting six years of campaigning on
repeal and replace and then when it came
right down to it they wouldn't do it how
do you explain that in the spectrum of
why people rejected the system it's that
part of that yeah but it's very much and
I think it's an indication of how the
the
Republican majority and president lack
ago you know coherent governing
philosophy but for six seven years yeah
every Republican said we're going to get
rid of Obamacare and this is again one
of the stories I tell is the creation of
the perpetual outrage machine out there
the click serve it is who you know we're
ginning up the base and making promises
they could not fulfill making promises
that were unrealistic and then then when
they were not realized then convincing
that base that they were being being
betrayed they'd been stabbed in the back
you people are being screwed and that we
needed to rise up so what happened was
we created this this dynamic of
over-promising under-delivering
and then you know stoking the outrage
machine so now suddenly the Republicans
are the dog that catches the car they
have Congress and they have a president
and say okay what are you gonna do with
Obamacare and it turns out they didn't
really have any good answers and they
had a president who could not be
bothered either to learn the details of
the policy or to sell the policy so we
ended up with and you and I probably
remember when we complained about
Obamacare being rammed through you know
how they rushed it through okay yeah
well how silly that sounds come compared
to what the Republicans wanted to do
without without a single hearing without
any debate the President did not hold a
single town hall meeting there were no
speeches there was no selling and yet
somehow we're surprised that that failed
look I understand that I think the worst
thing that's happened to conservatives
in in Alaska and last eight months is
that is is is is this desire constantly
to enable the dysfunction to rationalize
the fact that you have a president who
will not lead and and then to define a
scapegoat I think for many Trump
supporters Trump cannot fail you can
only be betrayed you can only be stabbed
in the back so there's this constant
search for someone else to shift the
blame when it comes to a president who
would not lead is there anything he
could do that would soften your rhetoric
about you've called him many many things
and you've condemned him effectively
I've described well is there anything he
can do and and again your operating have
you met the president by the way I've
spoken to the press you've spoken to him
so your conclusions are based on what
you've seen and and you've made
judgments which is what our job is to do
is to come to judgments but is there
anything that he could do that would in
in his efforts to lead in the
accomplishments he's had so far what is
there anything you can praise whether it
is the response to the Hurricanes the
the the stock market the efforts and his
at least the vision and his goals that
he's trying to have other people help in
implementing anything there at all that
would be no what's it like describe of
the book that you know I describe myself
as a contrarian conservative I'm estilo
concerned now what does that mean it
does not mean mindless opposition it
does not mean that I'm against
everything he does in fact you know we
want to push him with it when he does
something you agree with you applaud him
like for example the judicial
appointments which have been outstanding
than many of the other things I think
some of the other executive orders have
been really pushing the country in the
right direction on the and and push him
to do more of the right things but also
you know what I'm I'm not in the cult of
personality I don't feel that though
Donald Trump's personal success needs to
be defended on at every particular case
I'm not gonna rationalize or pretend
when he's behaving in a buffoonish
clownish way that he's not behaving in a
buffoonish clownish way when he is
reckless and dangerous I think he needs
to be called reckless and and dangerous
when he is betraying fundamental
conservative values I think the
conservative need to say he's betraying
conservative values so that's that point
of Independence and I would hope the
conservatives understand I mean this may
be the ultimate and I know you
understand this Pyrrhic victory for
Republicans Pyrrhic victory is you win
you win the battle but at such a cost
you lose the war and unless we stand up
we're gonna be stained by all of this I
mean are we really is our conservatives
really going to rationalize and defend
and support everything this president
does are we gonna pretend that certain
things are not happening is
worth working so that in fact there's at
least even four people hearing this
program getting a certain impression
that all is lost when we've described
his certain successes if he is the
person you described it's fascinating
that certain some successes can happen
certain judgment is there his it the
praise he's received in Houston
certainly in Florida his his his he's
been in Puerto Rico now and workings
well I think though that again there's
politics everywhere and we we know the
difference between mayor's who are
Democrats who are who are working to
make sure that this what some people say
is a narrative which is to denigrate him
enough to where nothing can get done
people are concerned that that's what's
happening from is not the victim here
Obama trauma is not a victim and you
know what about this is the thing that
fascinates me about him you see his
support of his supporters believe that
well he's fights he's a leader he's
strong
actually he's thin-skinned and waning
and he plays the victim card he's a good
man who can't take the punch he punches
back but how is this though when you're
saying we want him to succeed or at
least and you can't do that by just
simply being in groupthink or supporting
him how does that conversation and that
those accusations are descriptions how
does that help us actually encourage
someone to be a leader and to engage a
lot of people think that that it doesn't
that this is this is not
forward-thinking at all when it comes to
the president and the governing of the
country at this point with everything
that's happening well you know my focus
and and I try to do this because look at
Donald Trump is Donald trum but he's
good to be who he's gonna be you know
and he's he's living his life he's he's
a billionaire he's the president he's
married to a supermodel he's you know
his but I want to shift the the focus a
little bit to what is he doing to us
what is he doing to conservatives what
is he doing to the Republican Party what
is he doing to the culture what is he
doing to our the level of our discourse
because after Donald Trump leaves office
whatever his political accomplished
and some will be positive and some will
be negative I think that that the damage
that he's doing to causes that I believe
in and that I care about there's going
to be long lasting I also think the
damage to the country is going to be
long-lasting because you know first of
all look the crudity the dishonest
we don't mean his style we know you
don't like it's done well I know that
you don't like his style because you've
described him in these terms as well
before you decided to support me that's
but that's that's an interesting point
though too because I mean didn't at one
point you said the Republicans don't
need to sacrifice their dignity and
their principles look this is and I
think that's though this is part of the
important conversation of recognizing
and us going through a very passionate
political framework seeing on the
surface immediately what we're going to
respond to as individuals for me as a
feminist as a woman as a gay woman and
believing that there could be certain
alternatives always we remember Reagan
and but remaining engaged seeing what
the alternatives are what those
conversations have been what is being
misrepresented and what is not and then
coming to a conclusion I think as
certainly as many women did that in fact
you know he isn't necessarily the man
we're going to be married we're not
looking for a boyfriend but that the
nation was at such a point and remains
at a height where in fact yes we're
looking for leadership we're looking for
someone who's going to change the
trajectory and those are those are
things when we're making political
decisions and voting and the difference
between the by what we chose what we
what we think of again the nature of
what our job has been and what the job
we expect of him to be and so this is
where this happens but if we're talking
about the country and damage and with
your concerns certainly about the
president and we talk about what
Congress has become good and its
dysfunction and what you what you write
about here about a you are the people
you admire Paul Ryan that the history of
the conservatism which people must want
to know that there's a section in here
which is very helpful in the sense of
the nature of what the conservative
intellectual world has been what it is
now and what matters to you and where
this foundation is so what do you say
when when Bill Kristol is also tweeting
his anger on a regular basis on the
Twitter Paul Ryan yeah and Mitch
McConnell that you've you've got the
basis separate from Trump of damage of
change of being unable to then present
something or win or present an
alternative all of the men and the woman
that was up on that stage unable to
defeat him doesn't that speak about the
party itself or the lack of leadership
whoa no I mean I mean that's the core of
the issue this is this is an interesting
question because one of the questions I
had to ask was you know is does Donald
Trump represent you know continuity or
discontinuity in the conservative
movement in the Republican Party was was
this a hostile takeover of an otherwise
healthy party was at a Black Swan event
and ultimately came to the conclusion
the dysfunction in the Republican Party
was a pre-existing condition obviously
Donald Trump is a symptom of things that
are wrong in the Republican Party rather
than simply in effect I mean obviously
he is in effect as well and I think
they're seeing some of all of those
divisions all of that incoherence
playing out on a national stage but I
mean it is look where we're at right now
you know you know Republicans control
the presidency the house and the Senate
you know theoretically a majority of the
Supreme Court and yet what is getting
done what is getting accomplished and
and I think this is that moment you step
back and you go okay you know what
Republican Party had gotten very good at
being at understanding what it was
against uniting and you know hate Barack
Obama we really want to beat Hillary
Clinton we want to make we want to make
liberals cry you know liberal tears or a
go we hate the news media but what are
our policy answers and can we unite
around those policy answers and the
answer turns out to be at least as well
we're sitting here right now a big
question mark whether or not we may get
to the end of the year without a single
major legislative accomplishment now
that is an indictment of the entire
Republican Party
starting from the president down through
Congress there's a view though that that
is deliberate that congressional
leadership who have also been very very
critical of the president are not
interested in helping him succeed do you
agree with that or not what do you think
well let's first of all almost all the
problems the Donald Trump is experienced
is first eight months have been
self-inflicted I understand that he
likes to play the victim card here but
the gaffes the comments the you know
decision to fire the FBI director you
know the the a variety of these things
have been done to himself so to the
extent that the Donald Trump is not
succeeding the buck stops there
remember when Harry Truman had the buck
stops here can you imagine that that on
Donald Trump's desk it's like there's
not the buck stops there's who can I
blame who can i you know tweet storm but
but look I'm very critical of Paul Ryan
who I consider a friend because in fact
I think he's made a Faustian bargain
with Donald Trump that he is working so
hard to get some of this legislation
through like tax reform but he's willing
to overlook a lot of things that the
president has done and a lot of things
that he that he has said so keep in mind
the House of Representatives did pass an
Obamacare repeal I keep in mind that the
house represented is likely to pass some
sort of a tax reform so you know
ultimately at what point does the buck
stop with Donald Trump I mean I
understand the people who feel the need
to to defend Donald Trump but at some
point doesn't aren't those defenses
enabling him get out from behind the you
know your your your Twitter account and
go talk to the American people about
taxes go explain why you can boost thing
and maybe by the way while you're doing
that why don't you release your own tax
return you know and tell the other you
know swamp creatures you brought to
Washington there's you know stop milking
the taxpayers on all these flights but
get out there and actually start talking
about these issues where what is the
leadership on on health care where was
the leadership on on town taxes well
with when many people see when the house
does something and of course as we've
discussed the GOP is in control
of the entire government the Senate is
not on another planet they know what's
happening they of course know each other
their leadership together its leadership
at the party
a lot of people have grown past the idea
that that there is this genuine fight or
at least there's a recognition that the
Republicans in the House can say well we
did pass this and the Senate just can't
figure out what to do it seems to be
then the the convenient end where then
nothing does get done so you have the
motion of like what we did X and at
first it was well we can't do anything
about Obamacare or taxes or anything
until we get the house so we gave them
the right then we can't do it until we
get the Senate we gave them the set
right no we can't do it until we get the
White House gave them the White House or
at least someone who articulated during
the campaigns exactly what his focus was
going to be Obamacare taxes jobs the
economy and yet it's as though there's
this convenience stoppage in the Senate
that then we talk about self-inflicted
wounds or not separate from the
president's other choices on the agenda
and legislatively that buck stops at
Congress at this point of getting things
into the White House onto his desk let
me let me suggest that that maybe it
turned out in retrospect that that
making a reality TV star President
United States who had no political
experience whatsoever and was known to
have serial problems with with the truth
and no ability to politically lead in
this particular way maybe that wasn't a
good idea
or the people though that handling
legislation and getting it through have
been in there for decades president is
the new person and to suggest that with
all of the experience that the
Republicans have and McConnell certainly
Speaker Ryan and and John McCain decades
of knowing what the process is to blame
it on the president exclusively this is
where people say what this does is not
making so much sense where where ken
McConnell go what should he be doing is
this
the senate obstructing is it time for a
new leadership this is the other
question is it time for the GOP to
actually have new leadership that's
interested in legislation and moving
things forward
well yes but are you talking about the
president or are you talking about that
I've been talking about congressional
leadership I find it I understand
they've been in there for decades in
1981 you not had an answer that area
well I 1981 massive tax cuts were passed
what are they known as the Reagan tax
cuts right
yeah because Ronald Reagan was the
President of the United States Ronald
Reagan didn't make excuses
do you know Democrats controlled
Congress you know there were
relationships
absolutely yeah because because the
president didn't spend time on Twitter
attacking people by name and destroying
them so you're saying McConnell is not
helping and obstructing because he's not
seeing enough of Donald Trump look I'm
actually not defending I'm not defendant
what I'm saying is though is that is
this what conservatism has become
rationalization in carrying water for
Donald Trump as opposed to saying look
we conservatives we actually stand for
so let's talk about our ideas let's talk
about small government let's talk about
deficits do do we care about deficits do
we care about the national debt how do
we make people's lives better let's talk
about free market religiously what right
why don't we talk about free mismanage
that through legislation and we can have
that Donald Trump okay Donald Trump the
the conversation you and I are having is
exactly the conversation in some ways I
have with the left where the left says
you know Donald Trump is conservatives
he is the conservative movement he
represents everything you conservatives
have ever stood for oh they want and I
well isn't that the point you're making
no but see because they've they feel
that they have already spent years
denigrating right and controlling the
narrative about what conservatism is and
it's easier to put him in that box I've
been discussing and discussed constantly
but nobody's expected him to be a
conservative which is in fact maybe what
the point was was that we need a
businessman of action so I'm not arguing
at all that this is about the
conservative movement this is about
triage
this is about who you find in the
emergency room when you're brought in
and your your whoever that if that's the
emergency room doctor let's get this
done so that we can then move from
triage into getting back into our better
so generally if I wanted if I was and
that's a good analogy so you have a
medical crisis and it's triage in the
emergency room I bring in an experienced
doctor I don't bring in the reality TV
star I don't bring in the guy that
founded Trump University I don't bring
in somebody who has never been in a
hospital in his life who doesn't know
what he's doing and is known for making
promises he can't keep but I mean that's
the prophecy but Americans though did
see him in that way and have made that
determination some Americans saw him
that way well enough to where he's the
triage guy he yes and and so we if we
take that and have faith in that
decision for a moment and then you do
have the doctors and people who've been
in there experienced in Congress the
House and Senate who seem to not be able
to move in their area now you can always
bring it back to the president I
understand there's any more specific
let's talk about like why Obamacare
repeal failed well or or more even
though because this book what I what I
and you've also and I mean to get to
this as well because your background is
interesting your father's background is
interesting we actually both come from a
liberal right and here we are this this
is what excites me a great deal about
politics in the country here we are
talking about the conservative movement
I'm talking about triage
you're a Republican identifies more oh
you're not anymore I identify as a
conservative you do as well we are very
different rainfall and that is a bridge
also that hasn't even really been met
when it comes to if we both can be all
right people say I can't be a
conservative because I'm a gay woman oh
is it ridiculous and so those
conversations though the issue of faith
what it means to each of us as
individuals but this is a book about
this is personal this
and the politics of the last year been
personnel it's about what you stand for
what I stand for what we're worried
about we have we have interestingly the
same worries with different individuals
that we think need to be dealt with and
I do see and I think people felt
comfortable with voting for President
Trump because of the idea of the
individuals who were in Congress of the
balance of what would occur no one
expected Congress to be stalled and
that's what now
that's what's harming things even more
because of the passion in which people
feel about Trump and being against him
versus what can we do then as
conservatives legislatively through the
conversation to get things done and to
move past the vitriol of what the
American people did in the election is
it possible I don't know I mean
obviously we haven't done that yet and
you know I think it matter it's about
also a matter of what are what are the
priorities what what is the number-one
thing and if you asked 10 different
Republicans I think you might get 10
different answers about what the first
thing to do would be but as I said I
mean this this is where what we're
seeing exposed though are some real
problems in the conservative movement
and I there's a phrase I don't know that
I actually use it in the book but I use
it a lot which is the the fact that it
turned out that a lot of things that
that I believed in may have been
representative of zombie conservatism in
other words that we know we had been
saying the same thing for many many many
years as if the same solutions that were
applicable in the 1980s of the 1970s you
know are still you know art and there
still need to be applied right now that
we as conservatives have not adapted
that we haven't really changed our our
approach to issues sufficiently now some
people would argue well it wasn't that
what Donald Trump did and I do think
that he exploited some legitimate
grievances and some you know unfortunate
ways but let's face it you know this
should be the moment of maximum success
for the Republican Party as you pointed
out but people have saying you need you
to win all these things
and yet here we are and so it's more
than just Donald Trump and that's why I
tried in the book to talk about the
whole conservative movement and how it
sort of has been tearing itself apart
over decades and over years and that I
think is valuable in that not only your
personal story and how Americans change
politically right the Young Democrats
you go into to become a journalist which
is perfect pairing of course but then
just like as your father yeah a liberal
didn't like what he saw with the Vietnam
War adapted and changed to events that
were happening in in your lives
Americans arguably are going through the
very same thing right now and the value
of your view of the conservative
movement the intellectual element of the
definition of the eye that nature of
ideas but also we it's fluid that
conservatives are much more fluid
because they are open to ideas we have a
few moments here and at the end of your
book you discuss you have some advice
for you
with the goal of wanting the country to
succeed I have a goal of wanting the
President to see succeed which is part
of that what would you say to people as
we are trying to define ourselves in
triage saving the nation with a very
unique man at the helm
what can conservatives do what can
Congress do to bring us through this to
remain that shining city on him well I
think we need to go back to first
principles I think that we need to go
back to another concept that William F
Buckley and even Barry Goldwater talked
about what is conservatism it is the
balance of some competing values that
they that they fused and do ordered
liberty I also think that we need to go
back to first principles like for
example let's make sure that we do no
harm let's remember why the Constitution
was written the way it was it was not
written so that one party could get
everything it wanted to process actually
matters the rule of law matters respect
for the rule of law
matters it would be great if we could
get back to a moment where we would hold
each others to the same standards as
opposed to this world we live in right
now where we have complete moral
relativism where everybody switches
their standards depending on whose ox is
being gored I wish we could go back to
that and I frankly you know think that
the the the if there's a Venn diagram
between liberals and conservatives the
the overlapping the points of agreement
are very very small but they're very
very important things like truth the
rule of law the importance of the
balance of powers all of those things to
keep our democracy intact and also to
realize that we don't actually need to
keep up this cycle of hyper-partisan
hyperpolarization my real concern is
that our politics is not about ideas or
principles or accomplishments anymore
it's really become about tribal loyalty
it's become about attitude and it's
making us it's making us more divided
meaner and dumber in a lot of ways and I
would hope that intelligent voices on
both sides of the divide would find a
way to keep that kind of a conversation
going for the average person for the
voter who is not involved in politics so
much not even partisan and even for the
Democrats that voted for the president
their goal their agenda what they want
for the trencher they see yes the
sniping
the difficulties the hyper partisanship
the tribalism also as a problem yeah
right oh sure doesn't this then speak to
this idea that this constant argument
about what the president is or is not is
part of the problem he's clearly
transparent we know he's unique we're
all flawed but isn't this where America
kind of delivers is that we rise above
it together I think the president has
risen above the expectations himself
when it comes to how he's been handling
some crises isn't it isn't that what the
goal should be as then facilitated by a
working functioning government to do
things that help the average person
isn't that what the Republican Party and
conservatism stands for well yeah you
should start with the reality on the
ground and as opposed to any and
sort of ideological overlay it's like
making people's lives better are we
making it easier for kids to get into
the schools well they actually learn
things you know our city's safe do we
have Economic Opportunity and growth all
of those things you know do we have an
ethical framework of government but you
know the American people are good and
they're great they're decent and they're
resilient and you know hopefully they
can get through this I I think we will I
mean it's a very exciting time this is a
great book how the right lost its mind
maybe maybe not
you can disagree with that lots of great
stuff in here your background history
mate the intellectual history of the
movement and what we can and should be
doing great stuff Charlie Sykes Thanks